do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to talk about some
of the different things Game of Thrones
could do to shock us during the final
season I'm sure that most of you by now
have heard that there would be three
major shocking events over the course of
the game of Thrones television show now
I actually think there have been more
than bad but according to the
showrunners there would be three events
that would really catch the fans by
surprise they said the first one was the
burning of princess Shireen Baratheon
back in the fifth season then they said
the second one was when Hodor sacrificed
himself in season six now the last one
is said to take place in the final
season of the show as most of you know I
have made a few videos about this topic
already because I really want to know
what the final shocking event could be
this is something that most of us have
been thinking about ever since we heard
this would take place in the final
season I have always felt that it would
have something to do with the night King
since we don't know that much about him
already in fact I think most of the fans
are expecting it to have something to do
with the night king but I want to talk
about a different idea today I know that
some of you might call me crazy for even
entertaining this idea but let's just
have some fun with the topic now before
we get started I do want to make
something very clear like I said earlier
all I'm trying to do is think of a
different way they could shock the fans
for the third time just because I say
these things does not mean that I want
them to happen I just want to throw
around a different idea that you might
not have heard in other videos yet as I
was thinking about the topic again I
thought to myself what could they do
that would really shock their fans what
could they do that fans would not see
coming
so I came up with a different idea that
doesn't necessarily involve the night
king the first thing I want to talk
about has to do with Jaime Lannister one
of the last times we saw Jaime was when
he and Cersei were having an argument
about what they were going to do next
season Jaime felt like they had no
choice but to help Jonathan Aras because
he knows they cannot defeat Danny's
dragons
nor can they defeat the night king if
John and Danny would have
to lose that battle this caused a
disagreement between him and Cersei
which led to Jaime leaving King's
Landing now I think that most of us
assume Jaime is on his way to go try to
help John and Daenerys since that was
one of the last things he talked about
however even though Jaime might have
good intentions we all know he will not
be welcomed with open arms I think it's
only a matter of time before everyone
finds out Jaime was the one that
crippled bran Stark the northerners
already have more than enough reasons to
hate Jaime Lannister but this revelation
could send some of them right over the
edge at some time next season this has
to be addressed
Jaime and bran cannot be in the same
place at the same time without this
getting revealed after all this is
something we have all been waiting for
ever since the very first episode of the
show ended Jaime needs to look brain
stark right in his eyes and face the
consequences of his actions now I think
that most of us are expecting to get
this confrontation shortly after Jaime
arrives in Winterfell however that might
not be the case we all know how Game of
Thrones likes to make us wait and wait
and then wait some more even though
Jaime will most likely arrive in the
first episode they might not have the
big confrontation until much later now
when they finally do get around to Jaime
having to face justice most of us are
expecting bran stark to forgive Jaime
for what he had done to him we know that
brain stark has accepted his destiny of
becoming the new three-eyed Raven
therefore bran might see Jaime's actions
as something that had to happen most of
us are expecting Jaime to get out of
this somehow some way however just
because bran stark might forgive Jaime
that doesn't mean all of the other
Starks will forgive Jaime Sean's a stark
or arya stark might want to see Jaime
face some actual justice
even though Jaime might be trying to
change his life around I can just see
Arya Stark getting very angry when she
finds out Jaime attempted to murder her
brother
we know that Aria had her eyes set on
Jaime when he was having a feast with
Walder Frey now do any of you remember
what they were celebrating they were not
just celebrating because Jaime had
retaken Riverrun which was Ari as a
mother's childhood home but also because
that led to the blackfish getting killed
now we can already guess what all of the
other stark bannermen will have to say
about this they will most likely want to
see Jaime dead now we know Jaime
trying to do the right thing by leaving
Searcy he still wants to honor his end
of the agreement but what will happen
when he shows up in Winterfell without
Cersei support Cersei did tell them that
she would send all of her men to help
them fight the night king but Jaime will
not be showing up with all of their men
now I'm sure that Jaime will try to
explain what happened but will the
Starks actually trust him let's actually
think about everything the Lannisters
are responsible for Jaime damn near
killed Bryan Stark in the opening
episode because he was caught having sex
with Cersei then in the very next
episode Cersei tries to get Nymeria
executed for biting Joffrey now as we
all know they never found Nymeria
because Arya made sure that but Cersei
was completely fine having to settle
with lady then we know Cersei was
responsible for having Ned Stark locked
up in the black cells and that
eventually led to Ned getting executed
then of course we have the red wedding
Catelyn Stark Robb Stark his wife and
their unborn child were butchered thanks
to Tywin Lannister orchestrating the
entire thing we also can't forget what
Roose Bolton said right before he
delivered that fatal blow to Robb Stark
then we had Jamie and the Lannister
soldiers take Riverrun and killed the
blackfish now we know that Jaime wasn't
the one who killed all of these
characters however he is guilty by
association Cersei is the reason why
half of these things ended up happening
and everyone knows that Jaime has always
stood by Cersei this type of behavior
still continues til this day
Cersei agreed to work together to stop
the night king but she lied once again
Cersei is hoping that all of them are
killed and it's just a matter of time
before John and Danny realized this
unfortunately for Jamie
he might be held responsible for Circe's
actions considering they already have
more than enough reasons to want to see
Jaime dead now who could they have
killed Jaime that would shock us the
most if Jaime were to get executed who
would be the character we would not
suspect to be the one to do it
it would have to be one of the
characters that is closest to Jaime
which is Brienne I don't think too many
fans are expecting Brienne to execute
Jaime but can you imagine everyone's
reaction if she did some of you may not
know this but there is a very similar
scenario happening in the books right
now let me explain because I
don't know how many of you have read the
books after Catelyn Stark is murdered at
the red wedding they have her body
thrown into the river three days later
her body is found by their Brotherhood
without banners this is one beric
Dondarrion gets her the kiss of life
when Catelyn Stark is resurrected she
begins to go by the name of Lady
Stoneheart now she is on a mission to
kill anyone she believes was involved
with the red wedding she has already
started to have members of house for a
killed but she is desperately trying to
find Jaime Lannister you see right
before Robb Stark is killed in the
television show Roose Bolton says the
Lannisters send their regards but in the
books they say Jaime Lannister sends his
regards
you will give my regards to Lord Tywin I
trust tell Robb Stark I'm sorry couldn't
make his uncle's wedding the Lannisters
send their regards the Lannisters send
their regards
[Music]
ah
as if Caitlyn didn't already have enough
reasons to one Jamie dead this just adds
to that list of reasons well Lady
Stoneheart and the Brotherhood
eventually find Brienne who still
happens to be carrying that Valyrian
steel sword given to her by Jamie
even though Catelyn and Brienne were
once very close she can no longer trust
her she thinks that Brienne and Jamie
are working together Brienne is given a
choice Brienne can die right now or she
can go find Jaime Lannister and bring
him back to Lady Stoneheart to face
justice this is a very tough decision
for Brienne because she does have love
for Jaime
at first she cannot bring herself to
turn Jaime in so she almost sacrifices
herself along with Podrick and another
character all three of them have nooses
tied around their necks
however right as they're about to choke
to death Brienne yells out a single word
when she notices Podrick fighting for
his life that's when she changes her
mind she decides to go find Jaime and
bring him back to Lady Stoneheart the
only thing is Brienne can't just go to
Jaime and say hey Lady Stoneheart wants
to have a little chat with you Jaime
would never go do that alone because he
knows that would not end well so what is
Brienne do she lies to Jaime
she basically tricks him by saying that
Sansa is in trouble and she needs their
help
she tells Jaime that he must come with
her alone or else Anza will die now this
is where the story ends in the books as
of right now Brienne might actually be
leading Jaime to his death we will find
out how this ends and one of the next
books that are still to be released now
you might be wondering how this could
relate to the characters in the
television show well as we all know Lady
Stoneheart never appeared in Game of
Thrones we were hoping to see her in
season six but she never showed up
however almost all of us were expecting
one of the stark daughters to take on
the Lady Stoneheart persona some fans
thought it would be Sansa because her
character had grown to become much
darker while others said it would be
Arya because she was already so far gone
well I think we all know wait stark
daughter ended up becoming Lady
Stoneheart just like her mother does in
the books
Arya begins to wipe out every member of
House Frey she can get her hands on she
even comes very close to getting Jaime
Lannister only he was smart enough to
leave as soon as the sella bar
was over if Jamie would have stayed Arya
would have killed him too then of course
Arya was even on her way to kill Cersei
Lannister next but she went home to see
her family first
now what do you think Arya would have
done if she went to kill Cersei and
Jaime was there with her do you think
she would have only killed Cersei and
let Jamie go I don't think so
she would have killed them both so now
let's bring all of this all the way back
around we are all expecting bran stark
to forgive Jaime for his crimes but like
I said earlier that doesn't mean all of
the Starks will forgive Jaime now I
imagine that Brienne will be one of the
first characters to try to stand up for
Jaime and say that he is no longer the
same man that he once was but can House
Stark or even Daenerys truly believe
that Jaime might have given Brienne that
sword Annie might have even told Brienne
to find the stark daughters to save them
but Jamie has continued to do the wrong
things after this there was even a time
in the show when Jaime knew that he
might have to kill Brienne if she ever
got in his way
if you remember right before he retook
Riverrun which did result in the death
of the blackfish Brienne told him that
she would have to fight for the side of
the Starks Brienne said that we might
have to fight each other and Jaime still
did not stand down
Donna compels me to fight for thumbs of
kin of course it does
to fight you
let's hope it doesn't come to that even
as recently as last season Jamie tried
to kill Daenerys Targaryen he was
literally only a couple feet away from
killing her so when you start to think
about all of this I don't think it's too
crazy to think that Jaime might run into
some serious trouble when he is faced
with all of those crimes now as I have
said in some of my other videos I
believe Jaime will somehow find his way
out of this I would like to see Jaime go
on and do some good deeds but just
because that is what I want does not
mean that is what I will get I also
wanted to see Ned Stark take the Iron
Throne but that never happened either if
this third major event is really meant
to shock us then I think this is one of
the ways they could do it after it is
made public that Jaime tried to murder
bran one of the Starks could have
Brienne execute Jaime to show that she
isn't on the Lannister side just like
Lady Stoneheart one sort of doing the
books as of right now in the books
Marianas possibly leading Jaime to his
death so maybe they do something similar
in the television show next season now
that I have talked about this in the
video this would not really surprise any
of us but I think it would shock
millions of the other fans that have
been considered this outcome yet I know
this might sound crazy to some of you
but that's why it's meant to catch us
off guard let me know what you think
down below also before I end the video
I'm hoping that all of you can do
something for me I don't know if any of
you have noticed or not but whenever I
make a video I never ask any of you to
like the video the reason why I don't
ask is because I'm hoping that you like
the video on your own without me having
to ask you to do it as of right now I
think there has only been two other
times I have asked all of you to like
one of my videos I typically only ask
once a year on my birthday my birthday
was actually on Tuesday but since I did
not upload a video on that day I was
hoping that all of you could slap a like
on this video I would really appreciate
that and I also want to thank all of you
for the support that you have given me
over the past couple years to show my
appreciation I will be giving away
another set of the Ahsan of Ice and Fire
books there is a link down below for you
to enter good luck everyone and I hope
to see all of you come back for the next
video I have a great day I will see you
soon bye
you
you